Молоді, цілеспрямовані й сповнені мрій про море.
Так свій новий навчальний день розпочинають курсанти
одеського Морехідного коледжу імені Олександра Маринеска.
- Всі здорові?
- Так точно!
Нині у коледжі здобувають освіту тисяча сто курсантів.
Кожного із них сюди привели різні обставини.
Для одних море - сімейна справа.
У мене є дядько. Він моряк, раніше служив у морфлоті ЗСУ.
Та ще один татовий двоюрідний брат був капітаном.
Інших на вибір професії надихнули друзі.
Вони так із захопленням розповідали, і мені стало цікаво,
що ж тут такого, що ж з цим морем таке?
А хтось опинився в Одесі й вступив до коледжу… через війну.
Взагалі я жила в Херсонській області,
але через повномасштабне вторгнення нам довелося переїхати,
й від мого місця проживання не залишилося нічого...
Ці курсанти - майбутнє української морської галузі, яка наразі занепадає.
Через вторгнення РФ українські порти заблоковані,
а моряки зіштовхнулися з проблемою виїзду за кордон.
Про свою подальшу професійну реалізацію переймаються й курсанти коледжу.
Приміром, Леонід навчається на другому курсі й мріє стати капітаном.
Каже: від мрії відмовлятися не готовий,
тож сподівається на позитивний розвиток подій і… Збройні сили України.
Після того, як я закінчу цей коледж, я хочу вступити до вищої морської академії.
Я вступлю на 3-ій курс.
Тобто я закінчу усе через чотири роки.
Я сподіваюся, що за чотири роки ми переможемо у цій війні.
Леонід виріс біля моря.
За тим, що роблять з морем росіяни, спостерігає з особливим болем.
Я живу біля моря, тому я дуже часто ходжу до нього.
Не купаюся, але дивлюся на нього вечорами.
Я майже щотижня чую ці вибухи і читаю новини,
коли підривають різні сховища із зерном чи ще із чимось,
підривають крани чи влучають в різні кораблі.
А одного разу від удару росіян по Одесі постраждав і сам коледж.
У ніч з 19 на 20 липня прилетіло дві ворожі ракети,
150-200 метрів від коледжу.
І у нас повибивало більше половини вікон.
Деякі просто повибивало, деякі - разом з рамами.
Усі присутні тут, так би мовити, ліквідовували наслідки.
Ну, як на війні. Ми вже певною мірою до цього звикли.
Повномасштабна війна трансформувала звичне життя коледжу.
Приміром, тепер у Маринеско навчаються у дві зміни, аби всім вистачало місця у сховищі
під час повітряної тривоги.
А серед курсантів помітно побільшало переселенців
і дітей загиблих військовослужбовців.
Якщо раніше це були такі визначені категорії,
наприклад, діти-сироти, діти, позбавлені батьківського піклування,
то зараз ці категорії набагато ширші: діти з окупованих територій додалися,
діти загиблих захисників і захисниць,
діти з території активних бойових дій,
діти з території можливих бойових дій.
Також у коледжі навчається чимало дітей військових,
які нині боронять Україну зі зброєю в руках.
Приміром, поки батько Віолетти служить в ЗСУ,
дівчина вивчає транспортні технології й готується… піднімати економіку.
Оскільки мій тато зараз в ЗСУ,
а я навчаюсь на такій спеціальності,
яка в майбутньому потрібна в Україні, потрібна у нас в порту,
я хочу працювати тут і піднімати нашу економіку.
Я би дуже хотіла працювати у нас в порту.
Саме в Чорноморську.
Мені там все подобається. Нам розповідали класно про нього.
Більшість курсантів здобувають у коледжі професії,
які пов'язані з виходами в море.
А значить - із виїздом за кордон.
Наразі 12-місячну практику в міжнародних компаніях організовує коледж.
З серпня минулого року це питання вирішено.
До серпня наші курсанти взагалі не мали змогу виходити на практику.
Ми пояснили, що для курсантів плавальна практика - це невід'ємна частина підготовки.
Тож нині майбутніх моряків з України випускають.
Чого не скажеш про моряків чинних,
хоча ще рік тому Кабмін дозволив виїзд за кордон окремим групам моряків.
Зокрема, перша категорія - кадети,
друга - моряки, які прямують для роботи на суднах,
що здійснюють рейси до чи з морських портів України,
третя - інші моряки, які прямують для роботи на іноземних морських суднах
і перетинають сухопутній кордон.
Однак на практиці отримати дозвіл на виїзд з місця проживання дуже складно.
Особливо це стосується моряків, які належать до третьої категорії.
Органи ТЦК ТСП або відмовляють в наданні такого дозволу,
або затягують розгляд відповідної заяви про надання дозволу.
Це підтверджують і самі моряки.
Приміром, Володимир просидів без роботи більше року.
Разом із однодумцями моряк виходив на мітинги в Одесі.
І коли врешті Кабмін змінив правила виїзду для моряків, Володимир все одно не зміг отримати дозвіл.
Я подав свою першу заяву на видачу дозволу
з місця виїзду проживання, а саме це було вказано в постанові.
І на даний час вона не змінилася,
на що мені була надана відповідь, що начальником Генерального штабу
06.07.2022 було скасовано порядок надання цього дозволу.
А постанова, яка надає право виїзду морякам вийшла 2 вересня.
Тобто вийшов абсурд.
Володимир почав судитися із ТЦК і навіть виборов рішення на свою користь.
Перший суд визнав, що вони не мали права мені відмовляти
і що мою справу треба заново розглянути,
але військкомат не погодився і пішов на апеляцію.
У результаті суд не задовольнив апеляційну скаргу ТЦК,
проте й це не вирішило ситуації із виїздом.
Що трапилося після апеляції? Вона була в липні цього року,
а жодної відповіді від військкомату немає досі.
Тобто судове рішення не виконується.
Утім, Володимир все-таки зміг виїхати з України.
Каже: кордон перетинав без офіційного дозволу й без хабарів.
Мені написав один моряк, який ходив з нами на мітинги,
про те, що він виїхав, і розповів, що був потяг до Перемишля
і на кордоні була одна зміна, яка пропускала моряків з Одеси без дозволу військкомату.
Але потрібно було мати контракт, лист-запрошення і крю-лист.
Він казав, що якщо мені пощастить і я потраплю на цю зміну,
то мене пропустять. Багато моряків так їхали і багатьом відмовляли.
І ми сформували список змін і таким чином ми вгадали,
на якій зміні цей начальник буде, і я проїхав.
Нині Володимир живе у Німеччині. І навіть зміг сходити в один короткий рейс.
Каже: наразі до України повертатися не планує.
Як і його колеги з Одеси, які також виїхали без офіційного дозволу.
Є люди, які виїжджали через окуповані території.
Ціною свого життя, ми всі це розуміємо.
Бо там люди і пропадали, їх вбивали.
Тобто люди ризикували життям, щоби просто виїхати на свою роботу.
Також є ті, хто платив гроші і виїжджав.
Вони казали: "Краще я заплачу зараз, ніж вдвічі більше заплачу потім.
І я буду працювати, годувати свою сім'ю, бо замість мене годувати мою сім'ю ніхто не буде".
Труднощі із отриманням офіційного дозволу спровокували спалах корупції,
кажуть у фонді допомоги морякам.
Працівники галузі масово почали купувати "виїзди за кордон".
Хто має фінансову можливість - виїжджає за кордон.
На жаль, це корупційна складова.
Вони знаходять можливість чи придбати якусь довідку,
чи вирішити питання у військкоматі.
Це знає вся держава.
На жаль, ми підштовхуємо наших моряків на такі дії,
не даючи їм можливості офіційно вирішити питання свого працевлаштування.
І чим більше моряків виїжджатимуть з України з кінцями
- тим більше втрачатиме держава.
Адже до вторгнення РФ моряки щороку привозили в Україну близько трьох мільярдів доларів.
На жаль, зараз у багатьох моряків немає можливості виїжджати з України.
На мій погляд, це велика помилка.
Моряки привозять валюту і витрачають їх на території України.
Зараз нам треба жити, і ми витрачаємо нашу заробітну платню
на території інших країн і привозимо валюту в ці країни.
Нині Олег мешкає у Туреччині.
Каже, можливо, з часом переїде в іншу країну, яка межує з Україною.
Як багато родин моряків роблять:
що моряк повертається, наприклад, на територію Румунії чи Молдови,
їхні дружини з дітьми приїжджають до них, вони проводять свою відпустку.
І після завершення відпустки моряк їде на свою роботу, а родина повертається до України.
І хоча попри занепад мореплавної галузі в Україні
кількість бажаючих пов'язати своє життя з морем не зменшилася,
дедалі частіше навіть курсанти думають про переїзд за кордон.
Я взагалі хочу влаштуватися в якусь японську компанію,
тому що мені дуже подобаються їхні пропозиції.
Це дуже багато бонусів, зокрема можна вивезти свою родину за кордон.
Вони вивозять, надають якесь житло, якусь грошову допомогу.
Я би хотів свою родину вивезти, чесно кажучи.